Transcription: Khamala Manivong
Relecteur: Pauline Seguinot
Salut, donc on va
continuer sur le social,
mais je vais commencer
encore très fort.
On va commencer
sur la création d'entreprise.
Créer son entreprise, c'est le pied :
tu es ton propre patron ;
tu travailles quand tu veux ;
tu travailles au rythme que tu veux.
En fait, c'est du vent
toutes ces conneries,
parce que tu travailles tous les jours,
tous les week-ends et, pas de vacances.
(Rires)
Mais la création d'entreprise,
c'est aussi des mots très rigolos :
le « business model »;
le « business plan »,
la vision, la mission,
et puis, la question très rigolote :
« Et dans cinq ans, vous vous voyez où ? »
À part acheter une boule de cristal,
je n'ai pas la réponse.
Mais en fait, tout ça, ça me fait marrer,
parce que, moi, je l'ai découvert,
mais c'est indispensable.
Tout ça, ça fonctionne si ton marché
est connu, structuré, organisé,
ça fonctionne bien.
Moi, le mien, il ne l'est pas.
Il est très peu structuré, très peu
connu et surtout, le plus rigolo,
c'est que 95 % du marché sont
des associations à but non lucratif.
Et par-dessus, tu vas me dire,
j'ai créé mon entreprise.
Et je suis fier d'annoncer et de dire :
« Oui, j'ai créé mon entreprise qui sert
les personnes en situation de handicap. »
Oui, ça fait du bien.
Et c'est ça, moi, qui me fait
lever tous les matins,
et que j'ai envie de
vous transmettre aujourd'hui.
Tous les speakers l'ont dit avant,
c'est donner du sens,
donner de la valeur au mot « entreprise »,
au mot « entreprendre »,
d'avoir une mission
un peu sociale, sociétale,
que ce soit l'environnement ou le social.
Mais, on parle d'entreprise,
donc on va revenir à la base,
et on va exposer un peu les codes
puisque c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui.
Le handicap en France,
c'est 25 % de la population française,
soit grosso modo,
18 millions de personnes,
entre les chiffres de la police
et des syndicats.
Petite devinette : à votre avis,
combien de personnes conduisent
un fauteuil roulant dans notre pays ?
Trois pourcent.
Trois pourcent des 12 millions
conduisent un fauteuil roulant,
mais c'est lui qui demande
le plus d'aménagements
parce que si tu as un escalier,
ça devient vite très compliqué.
Aussi, un chiffre à savoir,
c'est que 80 % des handicaps
sont invisibles.
Moi, si j'enlève mes lunettes,
vous ne savez pas
que je ne vois absolument rien.
Mais, allons un peu plus loin.
Une personne en situation de handicap,
c'est entre 600 et 800 euros
d'allocations mensuelles,
un fauteuil roulant
entre 3 000 et 25 000 euros,
sans compter la pathologie,
l'aide à domicile, la santé.
Là vous dites, il est quand même gonflé
de venir avec une entreprise
dans ce monde-là
qui est quand même très fragile.
On va aller un peu plus loin.
Les établissements médico-sociaux,
sont gérés à 95 % par des associations
avec des fonds publics,
donc, qui dit fond public
dit forcément baisse des fonds publics,
et on a donc des structures qui comptent
leurs centimes à la fin du mois.
Et moi, j'arrive et je dis :
« Et les vacances ? le sport ? le loisir ? »
C'est quelque chose qui coince.
Mais rassurez-vous,
ça fonctionne très bien,
en fait, parce que c'est ça :
le sport santé, le sport
thérapeutique, le sport fait du bien.
Quand tu fais du parapente,
tu es là : « Ouah ! »
Les pieds et les mains
dans le vide, tu te sens libéré.
Je vais raconter une petite anecdote.
On a une de nos ambassadrices
qui habite Lyon.
Ça fait 30 ans qu'elle a la sclérose en
plaques et elle n'a jamais fait de sport.
On était aux Arcs ; on avait organisé
une journée sclérose en plaques et ski
et on l'a fait venir de Lyon.
On lui avait réservé une petite surprise,
c'est-à-dire, 45 min de ski -
45 minutes de ski pour nous,
c'est à peu près la base.
Mais 45 minutes, ça lui a changé la vie.
Juste de descendre sans fauteuil,
puisqu'elle est dans un siège,
ça lui a changé la vie.
Les larmes qu'elle avait à la fin !
Donc, c'est aussi ça d'avoir créé
son entreprise dans le handicap.
C'est de procurer ces sensations,
procurer l'envie de faire du sport aussi.
Mais revenons à la base,
l'entreprise sociale,
puisqu'on a les mêmes
problématiques que tout le monde :
Qui sont mes clients ? Qui paye
quoi, comment, pourquoi ?
Et donc, vous l'aurez compris,
ce ne sont pas ces personnes
fragiles qui payent chez nous,
mais des professionnels.
Et moi, quand un professionnel me dit :
« Mais Florian, le handi,
c'est 0,1 % de mon chiffre d'affaires »,
ce qu'il veut dire par là, c'est que
les gens ne sortent pas.
Pour lui, ils restent chez eux.
Et moi, ces hurluberlus -
parce qu'il faut faire preuve
de persévérance
pour vous adresser
aux écoles de ski - je leur dit :
« Oui mais, pourquoi tu n'as
que 0,1% et pas plus ? »
parce que sur les 12 millions,
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui,
nous, on a 130 000 personnes
dans notre réseau qui font du sport,
en France et en Suisse.
Et moi, ce directeur d'ESF, je lui dis :
« Oui, mais si tu ne dis pas
que ton activité est accessible,
personne ne viendra chez toi. »
Si mon voisin ne me dit pas
qu'il vend des pâquerettes,
jamais je n'irai en acheter chez lui.
Ce n'est pas lié au handicap,
c'est lié à la personne.
Au travers de ce speech de ce matin,
c'était ça que j'avais envie de
vous transmettre : donner du sens.
On l'a dit juste avant sur l'écologie.
On l'a dit encore juste avant
dans les speech précédents :
se lever le matin, donner du sens.
Moi, j'ai travaillé dans
l'industrie sur Annecy,
les roulements à billes par exemple,
et tous les jours, je faisais
la même chose aux mêmes heures.
Au bout d'un moment, tu te dis :
« Est-ce que c'est ça que je veux faire ?
le sens que je veux faire ? »
Ce n'est pas pour flatter mon ego -
ça fait longtemps
qu'il est parti boire une bière -
(Rires)
mais il faut donner un sens
à ce qu'on fait et se faire plaisir,
parce que moi, ça me fait kiffer grave,
et vous, vous devez trouver votre pied.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)